A bit earlier you changed some
permissions on the authorized key file
and the .ssh directory using
a command called chmod.
But what exactly does that mean?
Let's dive a bit deeper into how
Linux manages file permissions.
I've listed the contents of
the students' home directory.
And we're going to look at three
pieces of information provided here.
The first column we've
looked at briefly before.
Remember the d means
that this is a directory.
The dash means that it's a file.
Now, you might think that there are nine
additional spaces here for information,
but what's actually happening is
there are three separate sections and
each of those sections has
three pieces of information.
Let's break out this entry here for
bash.rc.
The three individual entries are rw-,
r--, and r--.
Let's go ahead and
label each of these entries.
This first one I'm labeling owner,
then group, and finally everyone.
This means the owner can read and
write the file.
The dash here indicates that
the owner cannot execute the file.
If they could, there would be an x here.
Users within the group can read
this file, but they cannot write or
execute it.
Finally, everyone can read this file,
but they cannot write or execute it.